the global food summit is a german
organization
dedicated to sustainable food production
at its annual conference
it brings together representatives from
food research and production
as well as other driving forces my name
is stefan becker sunshine and i'm
running the global food summit the
global food summit
is this year focused on bioeconomy
and food for an urban society we are a
think tank and
we are an interface between science
companies startups politics and
naturally also media in order to meet
the growing demand for food in an
increasingly densely populated world
creative solutions are needed food
should be easily produced
highly nutritious and cost-effective
like algae
our contribution is to make an
interpretation of the political agenda
and how it fits into a roadmap of
transformation
if you look at space how is food being
produced in space in the future it's a
closed
circular economy food economy and so
the learnings here have to be looked at
what does it mean if we run these
learnings here on earth
reshaping the economy from a fossil
based one to a sustainable one
based on renewable resources if we are
striving
for a global sustainable recycling
economy
we must be able to measure and compare
in a standardized way
the new methods that we want to
implement in
our production these measurements are
not yet defined in a way that
we can reliably say that they are
contributing
positively to the sustainable
development goals
so this is one very big question that we
have to
solve how do we measure a sustainability
approach
in bioeconomy and the second big
question which has to be solved is when
we talk about
bioeconomy in urban foods how can we
run this paradigm shift from a linear
production process
into a society and economy that
accepts that waste products are being
recycled and
reused also in food so these are the two
biggest problems that we have to work on
the global food summit acts as an
impulse giving innovator to accelerate
the change towards a circular economy
the bioeconomy approach is crucial for
this transformation
turning away from a fossil economy to
sustainable solutions that biotechnology
offers
using cells bacteria and other organic
material
on industrial scale well we believe that
the bioeconomy approach
will bring the greatest transformation
to us that has happened since the
industrialization in
the last 200 years so
with our work we want to create a or
contribute with a roadmap into the
sustainable future
and support as many ideas and companies
and scientists helping to
provide solutions to get into this
bioeconomical thinking in the future
things we are going to look at at our
performance on the 4th of november
between 10 and 1 o'clock